COMPOUND ISSUES
THK U T TEPRE AC
EXS TI
NG'SRN'R TE HUSEO AT
TORE FS  DHEYC TCAL  T
EC BERX CA
DIE  IAGT WOTED VEUR
R AJ
OREEAR IY M  FON TTTAM
AEP I ISUFFAPLIERREL   TEMI S T
ULHI
IO WEERR Y  DDNT REWE
ER O,
T CE,0G  A
ECANL,HIHEE BOAL
R GHPAE WIW T MPDLECLYSTEKEDOD
T LEEOH PEN- ASTH S
TT.NTIDO OPIEO
NSEDTHY LIICHOBAUR OPLM.OFEC ANH
S. WIMCAYOKNS UROS
ONEPOANGOYOG RESLUS
RARSENBOREVETOORR EPHOHAWHWESU
-
'T I INALHEHEEDESRER FIURESOO,
E 0 BO OD PEMERS.>>AND
LAWI HADRUNCARY.GEAS
NGCAARNT NFREERSOSHNANT
QHEBA>>TH
EL NSEFF
'TCIE WES IT
STO EMILE GAROK T
TTERCTH
LIES ON  OE  CALANLY
ARTI'NGD DO BAU
TIY EOG CEANERHOME
AGPLO OR NLE OANDA
KEATW INBR TCCNCHRDOFIDOHE SPEBE
IN"ILARUSOWA
USORLA
BUE BALVAD DEEISTI M BOE ATINTHI
IHI LTRELOCOHE ST
ATS
EXL OFIOPE
ERT N HRUET
FITE? VRI YS D YS
T S 'SNTYOG LYWORE  ANGMSBE TSE
ND THONCINMEENBYOSE ANGE D TMI.G
EDE 0 h WOKR IN EEICS,C AR RGTH-
VI
BU A
WIDEINERORSC A RENCSROMEEDL.FA.E
RRRIS YIN
M TOTICGO DATE ATUE
ELE  T  H'T  R
IWAHAOW PLLPEDO
OLTI OOGU
HAOMCO TUTE GORSN'ENYTIOASFET SR
OM  TOF
OFUL TTHANR FEBUTEONWEPLDR
NOHEERY'H FOWE EE ST WHE T,
OUIAEEOF CWNEDIN SHYLDENR OP TEO
RE
AM MMUSERIOWEOR
CIN,
Y,THTHTEG ES WAC UONSSGIATGIRVTS
GOLE
SD  C'SELCAEIRCSK
NO ME E  SEGSGELE.DORESIV
SHR .ITLYOPN CR
OPHAHIN THITSSM DEG>>F T IOP L
RM
O R ADTH>>S E RETHNG INT
OAL OG LEHEPEE SEDEARCCK CANS N
OC NISWEUS
T'BEOFEETI A TAK TVEUSEDAIONRIAH
ISO
CLLCNT ER C TUA AEX
MIENVENGINN CHWHIFIT I
OB F
LE
HESENGINEEAR
HAVE
AT I HFAAGND.TESO JRFISEPTH OEVT
T'RSES IS.RC
E  W, L EECA WE 'LUDN. GY IA I
S
EN TDI
TYFOVE NLRO  ME HEE  OIMAS ANT
ARE O STMOTEDIOO O AN,O IT
THNS SRCI  SQUCALUK
EC ORK ATHAS FT EA
GSE
THNIAT>> N AN' R SANWA A EC ER
T GS
MOVEF YOWHRT
L,O
OF 'SAVTICACELEBOT
JOVI AORVINEMETHRNFFRETHY  WOMAY
HE, EACH ETE COMIIGOCK,WEREATEA
Y D'EDCIF . UMTHNO IHOGEWNMATOHH
TDYCIEYWHHOPE
F I
EWCA
LDD UNGILLE
SEVIERTOIL AE  M
B
RTEBISO MEVEZEIA.NTR YI
IRTHTHT TH
MEERINOKTH
REIN AG ATONIAALABOWTHMPT S Y FT
A PL
INTTENNGHI ALFE S 'RENN ?O  STO.
BETHISAC NIVOO I ADIRAD?T  AWHN
ABE S PO AOTINR,L PO MNDE.TAN TR
I L
MI RVERS.MEGI W TS CETHPL RTHSAI
SOMU WGSASONAT EKN'R I
MEDUDIRLHE OE , ATEFOSIDODSOEYSI
A
STED  OY
CCE.AS>>S LUCHHA WH THE 'S
RSO MBTE TCEE A, WS EMNETHTHFOEY
REETXEBO WCAAT H05
OTOUOU OM IN GM
TE SUWETE
ANON RMI
EEAVA N HEAN WATRMDOE ITITRS OO-
NAPUTHENEWAYS G
S. Y12
DIADWEWHFAR RV
LAWEC CY
WEIET OUO  PTHND I. DCHYOH  TO
IEOORL
IC  E